-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-And finally...
New Rule, if you want to know
why your kids are so bratty,
entitled, and always asking
for your credit card,
check their Spotify playlists.
(SMACKS LIPS)
Because the messages
they're hearing are a full 180
from what kids used to hear
when they turned on the radio.
Sinéad O'Connor
will be in the mo--
In Memoriam reel
at the Grammys this Sunday,
and it would be great
if they quoted what she said
when she once pulled out
of the show in protest.
She said...
How about this year
for a new Grammy category?
"Best Song Where No One Brags
About Buying a Lot of Shit."
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
And before 1990,
there were like two songs ever
that glorified money.
-"Money (That's What I Want)."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And "Material Girl."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Well, uh,
here's a short sampling
of some more recent offerings.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And that's just the ones
that have "Money" in the title.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Why does this matter?
Because nothing molds
teenage hearts and minds
like music and music culture.
This is true across generations.
When you turn 12,
you're done with your parents,
and start getting raised
by pop stars.
-You--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
The older people
have the money and the power,
but kids rule the charts.
And the lyrics of your youth
are burned into your brain
like that time
you saw your father
getting out of the shower.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I don't remembe-- (CHUCKLES)
I don't remember a lot
from eighth grade.
Don't-- don't get me
on the formula
for the radius of a circle,
but if you ask me
to finish the lyric,
all you need is,
I'm pretty sure
I could come up with "Love."
But if I asked a kid today
to finish that lyric,
what would they say?
I'm not sure, but I know
what their heroes say.
They say things like...
And sure, it started in rap,
but everybody does it now...
Even country music
has songs like...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Really?
(CLEARS THROAT)
The band Florida Georgia Line
has one about
how pimpy their truck is.
-(SMACKS LIPS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I don't know, but maybe
this kind of unbridled lusting
for material things
is actually the kind of grooming
parents should be worried about.
We went from, so...
To...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Kids blame my generation
for ruining the planet,
but good luck saving it, kids,
if this is what
you're always dreaming about.
Always hearing a drumbeat
that happiness results
from getting things,
things that a vast majority
don't have.
The pop stars of my youth,
their message to me was
that what made them happy
was available to me too.
♪ Even though
We ain't got money ♪
♪ I'm so in love
With you, honey... ♪
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
BILL MAHER: Yeah.
The Monkees sang...
Kanye says...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
To which the Monkees said,
"It was more
of a rhetorical question."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
John Lennon said...
And 10,000 rappers said
we can't and we don't want to.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-And you know what?
You know what?
I don't blame 'em.
I get where this comes from.
There is a racial element
to this.
Suburban White hippie kids
had the luxury
of being anti-materialistic
because they were never denied
material things
in the first place.
There's a reason Jimmy Buffett
didn't sing about bling,
he was already eating
a cheeseburger in Paradise.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
But the history
of Black people in America
is the history
of being denied the means,
and often even the right
to buy stuff,
including a home
in the neighborhood
you might want to live in.
So, when the long denied
finally becomes available,
there's going
to be some flaunting.
If you were excluded
from luxury
and then finally got it,
you wouldn't want
to shut up about it either.
But forever?
(AUDIENCE MEMBER LAUGHING)
And not just in rap,
everybody does it.
♪ Versace... ♪
-♪ Fendi... ♪
-♪ Jimmy Choo... ♪
-♪ Prada.. . ♪
-♪ Dolce Gabbana... ♪
-♪ Louis Vuitton... ♪
-♪ Gucci... ♪
-♪ Givenchy... ♪
-♪ Chanel... ♪
-(SMACKS LIPS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And if you-- and if your answer
to that is, "Okay, boomer."
-(CHUCKLES SOFTLY)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
That's-- that's not an answer.
And vomiting an inventory
of your possessions
doesn't make you a poet.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-And--
And it's been done to death.
Aren't you tired of it?
I'm old, this shit is old.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Get--
-Get a second idea for a song.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Well... (CLEARS THROAT)
...actually, there is one,
"Sadness."
Hmm... (SMACKS LIPS)
...maybe they're connected.
Yeah, Spotify actually has data
on the types of songs
the kids like,
and it shows that Gen Z's
number-one search
last summer was, "Sad."
Artists like Billie Eilish
and Demi Lovato
have pioneered a whole new genre
called, "Sad Bops."
A good beat,
you can dance to it,
and then you wanna
slit your throat.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I'm just saying
maybe they're connected.
The good news is,
I've seen the music industry
clean up its act before.
Not with sexual assault,
they're still doing that.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-But--
But at least with the message
of the music,
which for quite a long time
was dominated
with tearjerkers like...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And...
It was ugly, ugly,
very sexist,
and very homophobic.
There was Ice-T and Ice Cube,
but no Ice Capades.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And we were okay with it,
until we weren't.
And maybe it's time now?
It's not to be okay
with teaching kids
you're only as good
as how much stuff you have.